hey today we're gonna talk about seven
signs that might show you you're more
intelligent smarter than you think you
are don't you know that is actually a
lot of smart people out there in the
world I know sometimes it doesn't look
like it especially when we look at the
news and social media but that's only
because the dumbest people out there are
usually the ones that's the loudest the
ones that makes the most noise smart
people they simply don't advertise that
they are smart because they try to live
their lives in such a way that they
don't draw unnecessary attention to
themselves and most of them don't even
think that they are smart anyway let's
not waste any more time let's get right
into the video
[Music]
I made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong I just very quick if you're new
here to my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle
subscribe also click that notification
bell and so you won't miss any of the
next videos no let's start with the
first sign smart people understand that
they don't know everything
I study posted in the Journal of
Personality and Social Psychology showed
that the less intelligent you are the
more you overestimate your cognitive
abilities so in other words you know
that that person who always thinks he's
right well actually he's not that smart
smart people on the other hand they are
able to admit that they don't know
something about a certain topic because
the more intelligent they are the more
they realize just how much there is how
much space there is to learn more and
how much they don't actually really know
such thing is that people who think that
they know everything all the time that
gets stuck in life they don't grow
anymore because they think that they're
already the expert on everything so they
never learn and never grow
intelligent people are very sensitive to
other people's experiences a lot of
psychologists argue that empathy is a
core component of emotional intelligence
so in other words if you care about the
needs and also the feelings of other
people and you act in a way that is
sensitive to those needs and feelings
then chances are you're a lot smarter
than you think you are smart people
understand and almost kind of feel what
somebody else is going through that's
probably why the politicians are the
dumbest people in this world because
they can't do it open-minded smart
people are always open to new ideas or
alternative solutions because they know
if they have more information out there
and more options then they'll be able to
make better decisions they try not to
let their own biased assumptions or
perceptions get in the way of truly
understanding something so they're
willing to consider and accept different
views from different people psychologist
says that they tend to score higher on
the SAT and on intelligence tests and
remember this your mind is like a
parachute it only works when it's open
smart people like their own company now
this is an interesting one because
studies from the British Journal of
Psychology shows that smarter people
actually gets less satisfaction than
most people from socializing with
friends
so if you're very individualistic then
you're probably highly intelligent
you're highly adaptable if you're
flexible and able to handle new
situations very well then you're very
smart because it shows you what you can
accomplish regardless of the problems
you face psychological research shows us
that intelligent people are able to
change their own behaviors so that they
can adapt easier to situations or they
make changes to the environment
themselves smart people are always
curious and they always ask the right
questions and the big questions about
life Albert Einstein said I have no
special talents I am only passionately
here
your friends tell you hey I think you're
a really good listener then chances are
you're probably very intelligent why
because when you talk to a smart person
there's one thing I'll always realize
you will never try to hijack the whole
conversation or even talk for a very
long time without giving someone else
the chance to also say what is on their
mind they actually want to listen to
what you have to say think about it
carefully and then when they do speak or
ask the question they hit that sweet
spot they give good advice that will
also cause you to come at the right
conclusion by yourself you tend to be
very self-critical it's great to see how
smart people are great at taking good
honest critique from other people and
even from themselves compared to plus
puffed up people who sometimes lie to
themselves and others about how good
they are at something you know those
puffed up people intelligent people on
the other hand are humble enough to see
their own faults they have the courage
to admit it as well and then they have
the wisdom to correct it if you liked
the video give it a thumbs up subscribe
and also watch some of my other videos
over here and then we will talk soon
[Music]
Oh
[Music]